good afternoon everybody this is a time
to wake up again and I really want to
thank Michael and David for being the
warm-up band here this is the main act
before I start I would like you to hit
get up like this if you're here you read
the abstract you downloaded dr. racket
you're ready to win a price realm of
racket signed by the of one of the
others there are 13 more to collect
after that okay and the way to get that
is to install a little package in your
doctor record you do that by going to
the file menu you say install package
and you type s as in Strange Loop L as
in loop two zeros one for before so that
you listen it's not five it's four and
then hit okay everybody listening and
hit install and you're ready to go okay
so Mike and David said Big Bang in 1930
it was actually nineteen twenty six to
seven when girdle was visiting Prince
King and Alonso came up with lambda
calculus it took 13 years to publish
this day we take 30 minutes to publish
an idea that we had in the future right
something like that so I want you to
imagine the worst think ahead think of
it more ahead imagine your children in
middle school it's one of the worst
thoughts you can have I'm through that
some of you are up flat right okay so
that just about figured out one plus one
equals two
now that hitting them with questions
like hey if X is 5 and Y is 3 what's x
times y plus 8 or they're telling them a
horse buggy is leaving San Luis
at five miles an hour going to Chicago
when it's gonna get there or how high
it's gonna be from here until X hours
from now right and that's how we drone
our nun children have been doing it for
hundred years maybe 150 years in
American schools everywhere in the world
and all we get out of that is boredom so
what numbers who cares about numbers why
don't we use pictures and animations
that's the starting point for Big Bang
was 1995 when I collected my research
group I mean said we can do better we
should be able to turn this math into
something that works on computers okay
well so to start with you have
arithmetic of images instead of an
arithmetic of numbers why don't we add a
green circle and a brown rectangle
different kind of ads and one plus one
what do you get you get a little treat
well as opposed to have X is a horse
pucky and y is a white background with a
tree on it what happens if you put the
horse buggy at zero 100 well you guessed
it you get a horse buggy on the white
background what if we changed this word
problem a little bit about the horse
buggy going from st. Louis to Chicago
and say don't bother with computing the
stuff but draw the picture right draw a
table of where's it at 10 was it 50 was
120 why would we do that because if we
put all those things together we can ask
them to come up with this kind of
function it's called a variable
expression technically in middle schools
with middle school teacher apologize for
abusing the terminology but that's what
they're really asked for given T place
the horse buggy at five times T five
miles now remember in this white
background which represents the distance
between
Louis and Chicago and what you get is a
whole bunch of pictures you guessed it
if you play this very quickly you've got
an animation right so you can easily
turn those problem sets into something
we in his audience can turn this problem
set some middle school is something that
goes for an animation as opposed to
boring little calculations with numbers
so back to 1995 what did we really try
to accomplish the idea was to combine
mathematical subjects like math or in
high school maybe physics with
programming and so that programming
would help the mathematical disciplines
and mathematical disciplines would help
there's a back and forth there's a
synthesis between the two of them what I
don't care about is programming per se I
want to repeat that I don't care about
programming per se I think it is a
mistake of all of us to think that we
need to teach programming we should
teach something so that kids who walk
away from there from this middle school
never program again but become doctors
and journalists and artists take
something out of that thing that
synthesis of math and programming and
what you don't know what I'm talking
about
here's the bottom line I mean bottom
line as in money there's a study a
longitudinal study by the US the OED
Department of Education that predicts if
you understand the concept of function
under all other circumstances equal your
income will be higher at 30 right your
understanding of the concept of function
middle school predicts your income at 30
the bottom line I said so right so my
dream was and whatever come what we've
accomplished this whole reason big
research team that we have here it's a
very smooth curve and what could that
curve mean a curve means you start
at middle school with a curriculum that
synthesizes this mouthy programming kind
of stuff you move on gradually very
gradually into high school with program
voltage scheme you move up to the first
year in college the curriculum called
higher some programs and you can take
this all the way to a junior level
course in software development and in
this day in age we actually conduct
research on this stuff we have pushed
this to the point where you're right
with middle school software we write DNS
proxy servers okay
that's possible so that is approximately
what I want to show you what I'm going
to show you precisely is how to program
in that world here's what I don't have
time for today I don't have time to show
you how to teach that stuff I don't have
time to show you that with all this work
comes the discipline of explicit
systematic program design I don't have
time to explain to you how explicit
systematic program design helps
problem-solving in the area of a search
a journalist an artist a poet okay
I don't have time to explain the
teaching languages to you I'll just show
you stuff I don't have time to show you
the IDE that we made simple so simple
that middle school kids can use them
okay so that's what I'm not talking
about so we are just going to the
programming so I'm going to start with
little demo gives you an idea how one on
one is added in our world is that
that form picking us up up in the top
thank you so one ant one if you add it
just like in middle school how do you
get pictures circle 60 solid green
woopsy right rectangles we make a 10 say
and the 50 and make a brown want and
what guess what if you put this above
each other
so I made a green tree completely green
eco-friendly right of course you can
also do other things on these things you
can actually insert a picture directly
into oops I'm going to do this
differently you can directly insert
images into the IDE because images are
values that's not not modern that's 1995
right so you have a horse car the host
body right in the thing and as you
already see you can name values naming
it is just like what they call a
variable expression witness that if X is
5 or we can say if top stands for circle
70s or the green and stem stands for
that and tree stands for that and we get
exactly what we would like we can for
example say tree or we can say court or
we can give you
I seen withered tree or a scene for the
card you can also write functions in
this world
this function down here says give me a
time T I will place the card at five
times T and fifty five height to the
right and top that's a location place
into a scene with a tree now kids can
actually instead of using the TI
calculator to calculate with numbers
they can say things like render it on to
and you get the tree or render at 55 and
you get another scene or you can say
animate this function what does animate
do it plays it very quickly it touched
the function starts at zero and just
keeps going what do you think is gonna
happen anybody this is a pop quiz what's
going to happen when I return the cards
gonna move right and we did nothing else
we literally moved we did nothing else
in these calculations but high school
pre-algebra middle school pre-algebra
that's exact material eighth grade and
we that's what we teach and other things
actually games too we will see this in a
moment in this world of mathematics
come on
let me go back to my talk so how do you
explain how do you explain this thing
when you get to high school what we
invented what we really meant is what I
call a functional system of i/o no more
naps required ok Big Bang is a new
language construct in which you describe
worlds so this is how you write it down
just kidding this is what it feels like
Big Bang we tell the kids in a
programming course is the representation
of a little operating system
what do little operating systems do for
you they deal with events that happen
for example
woopsy they deal with the clock tick
over there or a gamepad over there or a
mouse up there and I even had in a
brainwave reader but when I demoed it I
couldn't get any activity so I didn't do
that what I skipped was this little
green circle there this is a sheep it's
not secret it's a value that we give to
Minnie OS at to safeguard one value at
the beginning safe got that thing ok so
what happens when the clock ticks right
when the clock ticks Big Bang hands over
that little green value to the clock
tick handler a function that takes these
kind of values and you can do anything
it wants and compute with this value
when it's done that handler hands it
back to Big Bang and now you're kind of
done except that there's this purple
thing on the left your left right that
thing and I haven't talked about it yet
well every time one of those event
handlers deals with an event you get to
see that green thing move into this
rendering store
iliza it also does whatever it wants
with that green value and out pops a
picture for example we could externalize
in different ways like sounds taste this
is what it looks like in text that value
that your hand over is right there we
call this the state but it's just a
value it could be five it could be the
color green it could be an image could
any value in the world as you can think
of you can put them and then you have a
bunch of clauses where you describe the
world that you wish to create we call
these things worlds let's create a world
you can put in a lot of clauses the only
one that's really required is the
problem one that says to draw and what
these signatures tell you is that these
handlers and renderers take a state
something of type state and give you
something back no effects none okay so
to draw is a function that will take a
function that takes a state to an image
a kick handler takes one state and gives
a state back for example you might want
to run a club I will simulate a clock
you give it five one-time trick goes
away you get six back on key you also
have to give information about the keys
on a mouse click you want to say where
the mouse event happened and describe
the mouse event you can imagine many
many more handlers the yellow one is
another optional idea is you can say
let's close the world down when certain
conditions hold okay so this is the idea
let's demo that
I wanted to explain animate
what does animate do oops
animate says start counting at some time
I parameterize the function Wartell
which simulates this little trip from
st. Louis to Chicago and I say every
time the clock ticks have a function
that adds 1 to the number I give myself
here so for example if X 0 is 5 the
clock ticks at one puts 6 out brings it
back Big Bang now controls a 6 before
there's anything else its hands over
that number 2 the function render and
then you can run this thing just like
animate oops
so that's Wartell from Saint Louis to
Chicago starting at 10 and you saw the
horse pucky at 10 comes over now we've
explained animate this explanation is of
course exists because we want to show
students more than little animations we
want to show how to for example edit
little text boxes why don't we create
the text box let me show you first a
little bit about strings
hello strange look alright that's called
a string you've seen that kind of thing
I can make a big text out of that like a
222 purple sized text that's an image
okay I can of course string a pimp
and in our world we were very explicit
about one kind of things we add up so
and I would say no way hello strange
world okay now I can explain to you what
these little functions do here you see
another BIGBANG function it takes an s0
which we now say is a string and so the
state that it keeps track of is always a
string when you press a key
I will append that key to the end all I
have to do now is I have to display
every time the clock takes or every time
anything else happens after display that
hidden string from BIGBANG on to the
screen that's the function down there
and it uses nothing else but what we
have seen before plays an image here and
there you can run that
and you can edit well maybe you can edit
well nothing happened what's going on
your oh you can type that's good news
let's shift up that doesn't go well
right what's going on here let's start
with nothing I want to say hello capital
letters of course
hello strange loop and I get two shifts
what's going on
it's a row editor it just appears
keystrokes I have to give you one more
thing another idea that you get at that
level in school in ninth grade and
that's our first big success in 1995
fall of 1995 is conditional functions we
use that program something like that in
a school for football players this is
Texas right so they have to repeat
algebra from an eleventh grade from
seventh grade and they didn't know what
a sign function could do and our first
teacher brought is called it's a
conditional form what could that be it's
that kind of thing now imagine if you
can demonstrate that thing with an
actual conditional in the real world
what we do now is we are going to
replace string append plain string
append with a new function called shift
okay and that shift okay function down
here is a conditional function this one
has only two classes the key is
recognized as a shift don't do anything
just let the next that I go through okay
then you see string append as before so
you get the text big bang hands over the
text it hands over the keystroke
information which is just a string one
letter
and you PennDOT shift helps shift hello
world well I still can't delete things
yet that's not good we should be able to
delete things too right
oops and you can delete things by
putting in a function edit edit it's a
three branch conditional function you
still see the shift key part but you now
see the wrap out key wrap out key say
the last deletloss of course is also
conditional because if there is nothing
in the string you don't want to delete
anything right you can run that oops
textbooks hello oh and we delete it we
have a 10 line program and kids can now
understand how a textbook works it's
very different of course you can just
give them a text box and editor but
that's not good
really they won't understand so I have
added one more thing
namely a mouse event one-line addition
what do you think that does pop quiz I
give you the current text I give you
where the mouse events happened these
excellent y-coordinate it gives you
description of the mouse event what are
you gonna see if I move the mouse or my
text editor a blank let's try that out
this is important for you for you for
your price if you want to print when
you're in your prize line oops
oh yeah and there we go it goes away
okay so these things that you can very
easily bigbang distills everything down
to it is essentials it's completely
functional integrated mathematics and
gives you complete explanations of what
things are the universe from Big Bang
you go to worlds from worlds you go to
universes when each kid has a world
running on his or her computer they're
bored still because kids want snapchat
or at least text to each other
why don't we explain texting to each
other in the same way so in addition to
functional IO no mana is no small adds I
will give you a way of communicating
between worlds having an actual universe
with worlds floating around everywhere
so I didn't tell you the whole truth
because Big Bang can really be
introduced in little slices step by step
there's more the Big Bang when I told
you the yellow stuff is the new part of
Big Bang take example for the example on
tick you now see a signature to state to
state and possibly a message where does
this message go well you see a whole new
class at the bottom called register I
can give this world a description of
another world in the form of an IP
address and then every message that
comes out of one of those handlers if
there's one goes to that place so
somewhere out there on that machine that
is another OS that these kids write that
takes care of these messages and for
example it redistributes these messages
so messages can also come into a world
which is why we have one more line on
receive you get the current state
you get the message that arrived and you
do whatever you want you give back a
state or maybe a state and the message
so what sits in the center of the
universe of course a server and the
server is exactly and many of us it's
just a specialized world big bang world
that takes care of messages it does so
with a little value that it keeps track
of we can put anything there usually
it's a list of representations of all
the words that float around in my
universe there are handless for example
I can get a new world may show up and
say I want to register with you and then
we do something with the current state a
representation of that world and we come
back with a bundle on messages of course
a hand letter takes care of when a
message arrives in this central place it
takes the world that sent out this
message the message and also returns a
bundle so what's a bundle bundle is a
bit of a mouthful and we certainly
should be able to better some day but it
combines the state that we want next
with a list of mail messages and the
rest is irrelevant for our little
presentation here
what's the mail message the mail message
is a place where the message is supposed
to go a world combined with a message
all right it's time to demo again
I added two lines to the previous
program two lines the first one says so
second one says when I want to register
with localhost that's of course me so
they have a constant sitting there so I
can run this little distributed programs
and test them on their own local
computer and they have one handler on
receive that says lamb Daniel no lambda
by now all state and the message and
what a return is just the message so
clearly the arrival of a message wipes
out what you had typed in to your text
box there otherwise text box stays the
same so we still have about 15 lines of
code in here let me show you the central
thing this is the entire echo server it
will just broadcast any message that the
high school student sends in to all the
other guys that are out there and how
does it do that
you see echo it's a function ignore the
argument it has an empty list in there
there's nothing happening yet that's our
secret value for the mini OS and then we
say when a new world shows up on new we
add this world it's a function it's down
here and when a message comes in we
broadcast a message so how are these
functions working out right Outworld
takes the current state of the universe
u0 and the new world and all we do is we
add the new world to the list of worlds
otherwise we do nothing and that's the
bundle we give back to universe the
server broadcast it takes the state of
the universe the sender and the message
okay
and then it makes a bundle it repeats
the state around because there's no new
world we don't want to throw a world out
we might maybe we have only one wave
send email then you could do something
different but otherwise it's a map all
over this universe and create a mail
that goes to each of those worlds with
the current message it's a little map
thing and you've seen that in your
favorite language nothing else happens
how do you do that so this load this
module also loads the text box and I can
now launch these worlds I'm doing three
worlds one will show a another one will
show B the third one will show C and
then I can edit and hopefully things
show up everywhere else you see the a
world you see the B woopsy the B world
in the sea world and over here there's a
little window that tells me what message
is going back and forth the students can
see what's actually happening so now I
can go in here and I type in 1 2 3 I get
1 2 3 I go to the other world
I don't like 1 2 3 I say hello and I see
hello was the world and the last one can
say something too and say goodbye okay
and I kill this off I know you'll see
the console tells me universe is going
down and we're ready we are ready for a
little competition the box office opens
up and I would like you if you would
like to participate
oops
to launch your doctor racket nobody open
up your laptop's one person come on open
the laptops install the speech bag and I
don't saw the package this is a live
demo nobody else has the guts here to
give you a live demo as far as I know
I'm going to fail but at least I try
right okay
what you will do in your in your doctor
racket window you will type in this
require SL 2 0 1 4 remember the 4 is to
test whether you're listening when you
say speak hello strange tube or anything
else that's long enough
10 characters I am insisting that you
count to 10 and then it gives an IP
address the IP address is Antarctica dot
CCS dot na u dot e diem and it's encoded
string that's not that's it
ok and when you run that oh I got astray
what thank you okay so I'm gonna
register myself you see it disappeared
because the mouse is there so you have
to type something you I can't tell you
now what you have to type take your name
tag on the bottom right there's a four
digit number type in that number
the fourth caller will get a signed book
that says to the proud winner of
Strangelove 2015 ready go you have to
hit return that's the only change I made
to the program I'm gonna try two one two
three four five six seven
oops thanks if you see things you're
done you can no longer do anything okay
anybody try I don't hear any responses
louder
okay that's all good man you don't make
much noise okay I said the fourth corner
and the fourth caller has their number
where's four zero six six eight all
right coming up all right I have that's
it for demos
so what I showed you now up to this
point it's approximately what I have
been working through from sixth seventh
grade and and we actually use a
specialized Big Bang there it's called
game pad the kids have a narrative
they're worksheets and after about eight
or eight weeks or so they have a
full-fledged game a little video game
people jumping all over the place tough
like that you know 1980 style in high
school we have had a couple of
courageous teachers who actually did use
the connected world but in in their
college course the freshman course I
taught last time we certainly did this
and they had a ball that implemented the
last game in the book that he's bringing
back later and what we did from there a
couple of years ago we started with his
idea of we could actually push this
further remember this picture has all
these worlds out there and then as a
network that connects this special room
we seen his pattern over and over even
in Erlang our underground language that
Mike and David presented before and
skipped over other interesting languages
did you notice that come on
so the idea that we had was maybe we
could actually scale this up we could
build real systems in completely
functional manner and a completely
functional manner and what we we had the
key idea was to fold that blue thing to
make this blue thing an actual part of
the programming language okay and then
you have Worlds sitting inside this on
top of this blue thing and they can talk
to this blue thing what they do the way
that talk is kind of like what Peter
showed you in the first keynote you hand
out assertions and you make assertions
about assertions and assertions about
assertions that make assertions about
assertions you get that three levels
okay and you can go on and what you get
from that is publish/subscribe in a very
very different way you can also nest
these things so if you think of these
yellow guys as functional actors that
are launched when certain assertions
about assertions are interesting to them
you can also have a network inside and
nobody knows that this actor isn't just
the plain actor it's a network of actors
again another idea you can do you can
nest arbitrarily deep turtles all the
way up
usually it's down but you know the flag
goes up what do you get from that we get
a whole bunch of things but before I go
there I want to show you what you can do
with it well hopefully we haven't done
it yet but we are about to you can for
example replace one network and have
actors in different languages sitting
there one actor could be in Python
functional Python or sorry a good
language closure or something like that
well none of us would be a racket we
cook that we could even imagine some
some Haskell kind of thing you write or
another another network could be
replaced with a multi-core network and
you run this on top of the land and then
on top of a wide area network and all of
this can be done within the language and
you can slowly be cut down into pieces
what we what we have gotten so far we've
explored this world quite a bit with an
SSH server and DNS proxy server
you know chat server these kind of
things what you get is to a completely
different world of coordinated
concurrent groups of functional actors
and from that we get scope conversations
each of those groups can talk its
language of course we have hierarchies
of those conversations one thing you get
you get recent allocation oops
when one of those actors tour
we allocate the resources when one of
actors fails we remove the resources
each level can be tuned to the level in
the protocol if you have ten levels in
your protocol ten headers you have ten
levels each talks the level this
corresponds to one header everything
becomes a completely natural design okay
and now I'm going to put words into the
mouth of man who's actually doing that
where's Tony well he's here
if you see him you can ask him about all
these things because he spilled all
these things and he's here to talk about
it with anybody wants to talk about it
okay so that's Tony gone up chunks you
know and he's somewhere in the audience
and he is part of this stuff part of
people who built he's the lead part of
the people who built the last she steps
we saw now I want to leave here worth a
little take away that's not researching
there was just a bit of an illusion that
you can do research you can do work that
that's good in middle schools and you
can push it all the way to research it's
not amazing but what I want to leave you
with is this image we are this group I'm
not I'm just here as they're hot as the
guy who is the oldest in the group and
closest to death that's why I'm allowed
to talk here okay but it's all group of
like 10 20 people who work this all the
time we are the first ones ever to have
built a completely smooth curve of
programming that starts with tender
little six year old sixth graders and
goes all the way to the junior causing
college in a completely smooth manner
it's completely thought out it comes
with a whole bunch of baggage that is
not just programming but how did you
sign them systematically how to make the
sign explicit and how to have an IDE
that grows with you from the tender
young age
to the age when you're ready to join the
workforce that's what I would say thank
you very much for listening this is the
end